"
♪ ♪
>> Dana: WE ONLY HAVE ONE WEEK
TO GO AND SIGNS OF A RED WAVE
ARE KIND OF GETTING BIGGER THAN
EVER.
THE FINAL EXCEPTION OF THE
FOX NEWS POWER RANKING SHOWS
DANGEROUS TERRITORY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS SHOWING HOUSE MAJORITY
DECISIVE FOR ABOUT A ABOUT
BOOKENDS.
>> IF YOU GET PAST THE HEADLANDS
AND DIG DEEPER, YOU UNCOVER AN
INSIDIOUS AND INTENTIONAL
CAMPAIGN, REPUBLICAN BACKED
ZONES FOR FLOODING IN FAVOR OF
THEIR CANDIDATES TO CREATE A
NARRATIVE THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
SURGING IN A RIB WAVE IS SURGING
AND INEVITABLE.
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS ARE DOING
THEIR BEST TO STOP THE RED WAVE,
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA
ZIGZAGGING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BIDEN HASN'T BEEN SEEING OR HIGH
DEMAND, BUT HE HAS SHOWED UP IN
FLORIDA TRENDING TOWARD
REPUBLICANS.
>> THERE UNDER SIEGE BY OUR
REPUBLICAN FRIENDS.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS AIN'T YOUR
FATHER'S REPUBLICAN PARTY, IT'S
A DIFFERENT DEAL RIGHT NOW.
YOU'VE BEEN PAYING SOCIAL
SECURITY YOUR LIFE, YOUR DEBT.
THESE GUYS WANTED TO TAKE IT
AWAY.
WHO IN THE HILL DID THEY THINK
THEY ARE?
EXCUSE MY LANGUAGE.
END OF THE MONTH, WHAT YOU HAVE
LEFT, NO MONEY, THAT'S
INFLATION.
THE THINGS YOU NEED ARE GOING UP
IN PRICE.
GOD BLESS YOU ALL, GOD PROTECT
OUR TROOPS, AND GOD GIVE SOME OF
THEM ARE REPUBLICAN FRIENDS
>> Dana: FOR COPINOCCHIO'S,
THEIR WORST RATING, MIGHT'VE
DESERVED FIVE.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT YESTERDAY.
THIS IS LIKE A LAST-DITCH
EFFORT.
THE ONLY THING THAT TALKING
ABOUT IN THE ECONOMY IS THIS
VAGUE IDEAS THAT REPUBLICAN IS
GOING TO CUT MEDICARE.
>> THEY TRIED TO SELL THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT TO THE
MEDIA AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BUT THE POLLING SHOWS AMERICAN
PEOPLE DON'T ACTUALLY THINK THAT
THE BIG LEGISLATION THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S GOTTEN THROUGH
HAS BEEN POSITIVE FOR THE
ECONOMY OR FOR THEIR LIVES.
WHAT THEY SEE IS SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN GOOD AND SOMETHING
THEY CAN RUN ON, PHOTOS AND
SAYING, YES.
THAT'S WHY WE HIRED THEM FOR THE
JOB.
THEY'RE STRUGGLING WITH THAT.
THE OTHER THING IS TALKING ABOUT
LAST-MINUTE ISSUES THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN ANTIBIOTIC OF CONVERSATION
UNTIL THIS POINT.
IF YOU'RE PIVOTING YOUR MESSAGE
AWAY A WEEK AWAY FROM THE
ELECTION IN GEORGIA AND PLACES,
YOU'VE GOT A PROBLEM ON YOUR
HANDS ONE WEEK OUT.
>> BIDEN HAS RUN SO MANY WIT
RACES, I WONDER HOW MANY TIMES
HE SAID REPUBLICANS WOULD CUT
SOCIAL SOME SECURITY AND
MEDICARE AND ALL OF THAT.
YOU'VE BEEN RELUCTANT TO SAY RED
WAVE BUT WHICH A COMFORTABLE
LEVEL?
>> I'M COMFORTABLE WITH TSUNAMI
RIGHT NOW.
[LAUGHS]
IT WAS A LOOK LIKE A RED WAVE IN
AUGUST BUT NOT LOOKS LIKE A
SYNONYMY, I HAVE PIVOTED AS THE
EFFECTS OF CHANGED.
JOE REED NEEDS TO GET OUT OF MY
LANE, SHE IS NOT TALKING ABOUT
PATHS DOMINIC POT DOMINIC
FOX NEWS PULLS BEING FAVORABLE
TO REPUBLICANS BUT I HAVE THE
MOST INACCURATE AND INACCURATE
LIST OF POLES IN THE LAST
ELECTION.
THERE WERE COALS WERE CNN,
"L.A. TIMES," "WASHINGTON POST,"
ABC, AND YOUR TIMES.
THE MOST ACCURATE, ATLAS INTEL,
TRAFALGAR, AND HARRISON
RASMUSSEN.
THOSE ARE INDEPENDENT POLLS,
PEOPLE SAY THEIR CONSERVATIVE
LEANING BUT THEY ACTUALLY SPEAK
TO REPUBLICANS THAT WON'T SPEAK
TO MAINSTREAM POSTERS.
THEY'RE SAYING THERE'S NOT GONNA
BE A WAVE IN NEVADA.
IT'S AT NEVADA?
OR NEVADA?
THE REPUBLICANS ARE AHEAD IN THE
SENATE, IN THE GUBERNATORIAL
RACE, AND EVERY CONGRESSIONAL
RACE THERE IS EITHER A TOSS-UP
OR LEANING REPUBLICAN.
BIDEN'S GOING DOWN THERE TO TALK
ABOUT CHARLIE CRIST, THE FIX IS
IN.
THEY HAD A DEAL THAT HE'LL JUST
SAY NICE THINGS ABOUT BIDEN IN
FLORIDA AND THEN BLOODY UP TO
THE SENTENCE AND DON'T GET AN
INVESTOR'S SHIP, THAT'S THE DEAL
CUT DOWN THERE.
BUT THIS GUY IS GETTING WORSE AS
HE CAMPAIGNS.
HIS LIES ARE PILING UP.
HE TELLS A BIG LIE EVERY DAY.
REPUBLICANS WON OF SCRAP
SOCIAL SECURITY, THERE'S NO
RECESSION, INFLATION IN ZERO,
REPUBLICANS CAUSING THE CRIME
WAVE.
THIS IS BAD.
PINOCCHIO'S OR TO THE SKY.
I CAN SEE THE NOSE FROM HERE.
>> CALL FROM NEVADA, JOHN
RALSTON SAID, WE'LL HEAR WHAT HE
SAID.
>> I DON'T PUT ANY STOCK AND
PULLING RIGHT NOW.
WE'VE HAD PEOPLE VOTE ALREADY, A
QUARTER OF A MILLION PEOPLE IN
NEVADA.
I CHECKED THESE NUMBERS CLOSELY
AND IT LOOKS LIKE THE DEMOCRATS
ARE HOLDING THEIR REGISTRATION
IN NEVADA.
SO THERE ARE NO SIGNS OF A RED
WAVE, NO SIGNS OF BEING
DEMOCRATIC WIPEOUT COMING.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT CAN'T
HAPPEN.
>> HAROLD, IN NEVADA, INFLATION
FOR PEOPLE IS DOUBLE WHAT IT WAS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THEN THEY
HAD THE COVID LOSSES.
THERE IS A REALIGNMENT FOR BOTH
PARTIES HAPPENING.
NEVADA COULD BE THE PLACE WHERE
REPUBLICANS COULD FLIP THE
SENATE SEAT ON THE GUBERNATORIAL
SEAT.
>> THERE ARE FOUR SEATS IN THE
SENATE.
NEVADA, GEORGIA, PENNSYLVANIA,
AND ARIZONA.
NOW THE HOUSE, YOU HAVE TO
SEPARATE THESE CONVERSATIONS.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S A SYNONYMY
BUT I THINK IT'LL BE A PRETTY
GOOD NIGHT FOR REPUBLICANS
UNLESS SOMETHING DRAMATIC
HAPPENED.
IT'S NOT A SUBTLE SURPRISE BUT I
DON'T DISMISS THE MESSAGING.
IN THE SENATES IS DIFFERENT, THE
RACE IS STILL TIGHT.
IF WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS RIGHT,
REPUBLICANS COULD BE A HEAD AND
ALL THESE STATES.
THERE TIGHT RATES RACES AND
MAYBE THE MOVEMENT IS SHIFTING.
YOU PUT YOUR MOST GIFTED
POLITICAL ATHLETES OUT LAST WEEK
AND OBAMA CERTAINLY THAT.
YOU PUT VITAMIN IN SITUATIONAL
PLACES.
>> WHAT SITUATION WOULD THAT BE?
>> Harold: HILLARY CLINTON AS
IT IS PLAYER HERE IN NEW YORK.
>> THERE WAS A DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGY IS WHO SAID THAT KATHY
HOCHUL IN NEW YORK IS DRAGGING
DOWN ALL THE OTHER DEMOCRATS IN
THE STATE.
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED.
IT'S HARD TO THINK.
EVERY TIME JOY READS LIPSTICK IS
ON MY MIND.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO WEAR THAT
FOR YEARS.
FOX WILL ALLOW ME.
WHY WOULD ANYBODY LIE ABOUT A
RED WAVE?
WHEN YOU SAY IT'S A RED WAVE,
PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO ARE
INTRINSICALLY LAZY WILL LEAVE
THEIR BED.
YOU HAVE TO TELL PEOPLE LIKE ME
THAT MERCANTILISM THEN I'LL GET
OUT.
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO SUPPRESS THE
VOTE MY NEIGHBORHOOD BY SAYING
THAT ALL THE PEOPLE AT THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6 VOTED.
SO IF YOU VOTE YOUR NO BETTER
THAN AN INSURRECTIONIST.
TRY USING THAT.
I HOPE THERE ARE BLOWOUTS.
I DON'T WANT ANY DRAWN-OUT BEAS,
DO YOU?
BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S GOING TO
KEEP SAYING IT'S A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY OR THE SIN THAT,
THAT'S GOING TO UPSET MY
SCHEDULE BENCHING SOMEBODY
DURING A CHAMPIONSHIP GAME,
JOEL, BECAUSE IF YOU TOOK THE
FIELD HE WOULD LOSE, THAT'S
HUMBLING.
HE IS A MESS.
HE SING CRAZY STUFF.
DEMOCRATS WANTED TO BE LIKE THE
DARREN'S AND BEWITCHED, THEY
TAKE THEM OUT AND PUT IN THE NEW
DARRYNTON EVANS OBAMA BUT IT'S
MORE LIKE CHUCK FROM HAPPY DAYS.
DO YOU REMEMBER CHUCK?
THEY JUST DISAPPEARED CHUCK.
JOE IS THE CHUCK CUNNINGHAM OF
PRESIDENTS.
IF WE JUST KEEP THEM UPSTAIRS,
LIKE ANTHONY PERKINS AND, NOBODY
WILL SEE HIM.
I'M NOT AN ESSAY RED WAVE BUT I
THINK THERE WILL BE REPUBLICAN
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE ARE THE
SENATE MAY BE, AND WILL BE
PARENTS COMING HOME FROM THE
TWO-WEEK CRUISE, THE HOUSE
FILLED WITH KEGGERS BROKEN
WINDOWS, ADULTS ARE HOME AND
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO FIX
EVERYTHING.
WOE GIVES HAS BROKEN YOUR PARTY
RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU GET STRONG COMPETITION IN
THERE, HAROLD, THE DEMOCRATS
WILL COME OUT AS A MORE VIABLE
PARTY JUST LIKE YOU ARE A VIABLE
PERSON HAROLD.
>> Harold: I'M NOT CONVINCED
THAT'S THE CASE BUT IT'S MORE
RIGHT THAN WRONG.
>> ONE COMMENT.
THE MOST EFFECTIVE LION OF THE
RACE FOR REPUBLICANS GOING
AGAINST DEMOCRATS IS THE
CANDIDATE, THE DEMOCRAT VOTED A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE TIME WITH
BIDEN AND PELOSI.
THE ONE THAT DIDN'T WORK AT ALL,